[Music]
Ah,
Mera has already paid to stop Elias.
If that's what you want, we
can't stop it. What will happen to Mera? Just go ahead and
continue where you left off. That's what
we came here for.
Who is Hirome?  You're good at this kind of thing, aren't you? There's no
willpower in that child.
To me, no
one seems to care that Hirome is good at teaching.
Now you can say what you want.
Enemies and allies are all a mess.  I
want this in the mix What do you want? What do you want to do? If I want it, please
help me. You searched for you. To
meet you. It's not something you can easily touch. What should I do?
You used magic to solve puzzles, didn't you? A puzzle
involving multiple magics, all
with one magic trick. That tool I used earlier, I can also use it. I
thought about what I wanted, and the
cane wasn't enough.
[Music]
Strongly, the
woman in the coffin.  I am the howl of the beasts of your iron land, the underworld, and
you speak to the burning fields, and I put my hand on the coffin
[MUSIC]
OG